hi everyone thanks for coming my name is
Joshua Faulk I'm a data scientist at
civis analytics and today I'm gonna be
talking about generating realistic
differentially private data sets using
generative adversarial networks in case
it's easier for you to follow along or
you just want to see the slides
afterwards they're online at bitly /dp
WGA and all in caps so before I get into
like what each of the parts of this
title means I want to sort of motivate
what I'm talking about with a problem
you might encounter so the problem is
how can we make data available to
research but also protect the privacy of
people who appear in the data so to give
an example of what this might look like
maybe you have medical records and you
want to make these medical records
available for researchers so that they
can you know improve patient outcomes
develop new cures things like that but
right medical information is often very
sensitive and people might not want
their personal medical records just to
be out there in public for anyone to see
so how can we balance these concerns or
similarly maybe you do a study where
you're surveying people about who they
plan to vote for and again that could be
very valuable for political science
research but people might not want their
voting intentions to just be like out
there for anyone to see so how can we
take this kind of data make it available
for research but also protect the
privacy of the individuals whose data
appear in the original data so there's a
number of traditional approaches to
solving this kind of a problem one
approach is to aggregate or summarize
the data in some way report summary
statistics maybe means or medians or
standard deviations you might group by
certain subgroups in the data but among
other problems with this approach is
that it really limits the analyses you
can do right so first of all like
throwing any sort of more advanced
machine learning techniques under this
stuff is going to be really hard and you
also kind of have to guess in advance
what people are going to care about so
maybe you divide your data by one group
but someone cares about another grouping
there they just you can't they can't do
anything about it once you've released
that data
another approach that's out there is to
add noise to the original data and again
so you know so if you have like
continuous values maybe you had some
Gaussian noise to the data among other
problems this really diminishes your
utility so this basically destroys
almost all of the information that's
available in the original data if you're
gonna do it in a way that actually
protects privacy and a last approach
that used to be really popular
fortunately is becoming less popular as
people recognize its limitations is
removing personally identifying
information so this is things like you
know full name date of birth address so
you might say oh we'll just like strip
your name and address and date of birth
from the data and now we won't be able
to identify you you'll have privacy but
it's well known that this usually or
often doesn't really work and the reason
is there's a risk of what's known as a
reaiiy denta fication attack where maybe
your name isn't in the data set but
there still might be information in the
data set that uniquely identifies you
and so if someone can figure out which
record is yours then they can learn new
information about you that way and just
more broadly most of these techniques
it's often very hard to fully analyze
and understand the kind of privacy that
they offer and make real guarantees so
today I'm going to talk about an
alternative approach that tries to get
away from some of these problems and the
basic idea is instead we're gonna
generate fake data synthetic data that's
going to be individual level data and
that's going to look like the real data
that we started with and it's going to
preserve important statistical
information from the data so that people
can research with it so how does this
help with the problems we saw before so
for the problem of limited analyses
because we're producing individual level
data this mostly goes away right the
data is sort of in the same format as
what came in as the real stuff and so
any analysis that you could have run on
the original data you can run on this
fake data the diminished utility issue
that we saw with adding noise will see
that you need much less noise with this
kind of an approach to still protect
private
and so we'll be able to have data that
is has much more information in it and
with respect to the risk of a reai
identification attack because there are
no real people in the data right these
are all fake entries there's not really
a notion of oh this record belongs to
this real person so I identify them and
then I learn new information about them
now all of this being said generating
synthetic data on its own is not enough
to absolutely guarantee privacy and so
later in the talk I'll talk about why
that's the case and I'll talk about the
specifics of the approach that I'm
taking that do allow us to have real
privacy guarantees but this is the broad
outline of why this sort of synthetic
data approach is appealing so with that
sort of problem motivation I want to
give you an outline of what the talk is
going to look like so in the first part
I'm going to introduce differential
privacy and that's going to be the
framework that I'll use to sort of
analyze the privacy guarantees and make
privacy guarantees about the datasets
that we generate then I'm going to talk
about generative adversarial networks
which are a type of neural network and
that's gonna be the technique that I use
to make the fake data I'll talk very
briefly about a Python package that I've
written to implement these techniques
and then I'll apply the pout the package
to some data from the Census some
individual level data from the Census
and see how that data compares to the
real stuff that we used as input so to
start out with differential privacy how
we guarantee privacy rather than start
with a definition of differential
privacy I'm gonna give sort of a toy
example where we work our way up to
providing this kind of privacy guarantee
and then sort of explain how it works so
here's the toy example let's say that
you have a database of age information
about lots of different people and you
want to make this information available
to people in some useful way but you
don't want to reveal the age of any one
individual in the data set we're just
going to treat age as a sensitive
attribute for for our purposes here so
here's a possible first solution maybe
you only allow querying averages so if
this were like some sort of sequel
language you could
you know select average of age where
some condition that you want met and
then you return that average okay
there's a bit of a problem with this
which is we can say something like
what's the average age of people named
Betty White and if there's just one
Betty White and your dataset you'll get
the average of her age which is 97 and
now we have this one individuals exact
age that's not good right we've leaked
information about this person okay
now this might seem kind of silly right
you're like obviously when we said
average we didn't mean average of one we
meant average of a group so maybe you
place a little restriction on this and
now you say when you query that average
the group you're looking at has to have
at least 50 people so right before we do
the query we count how many people
satisfy the like where clause and as
long as that number is greater than 50
then we allow you to make that query so
let's walk through an attack that will
show that even this approach isn't quite
going to be enough so first we see how
many people are named Betty White or
John and let's say in our data set
there's 96 people who meet these
conditions right that's more than 50
great we can take the average and we ask
how many people are named John in our
data set that's gonna be 95 because
there's only one more person named Betty
White also more than 50 so we can ask
about the average so now we query for
the average age of these two groups and
we get that the average age of people
named Betty White or John is 49 and a
half and the average age of people named
John is 49 now we can take all these
numbers and get two more pieces of data
we can get the total age of people named
Betty White or John by multiplying the
average by the count and we can get the
total age of all people named John by
again multiplying the total by the count
and if we take the difference we get the
total age of all people named Betty
White namely the total age of the one
person named Betty White 97 so once
again we've leaked information about an
individual even though in theory we
thought oh we're only querying averages
of large groups so it turns out we can
make a slight modification to this
algorithm this technique to ensure
privacy and how is that going to work
again we're gonna say you have to query
at least 50 people when you're asking
for the average
but then rather than returning the exact
average we're gonna add just a little
bit of noise to the result so in this
case just for the sake of this example
let's say like some Gaussian or normally
distributed noise centered at zero with
standard deviation 0.25 so you know very
small you're gonna be like at most a
year off with your average so you're
gonna get some useful information out of
the queries but there is this little bit
of randomness so what happens when we
try this attack that we did before with
this modified algorithm do we still have
a problem so first we take the average
age of people named Betty White or John
and we get the true value 49.5 plus this
little bit of gaussian noise so in this
case we got 49.9 so that's pretty close
for a lot of applications that's going
to be good enough that's gonna be high
utility give you the information that
you need but it's a little bit different
than the true value and then we're going
to take the average age of people named
John again Plus this little bit of noise
we get 48.8 again pretty close to the
true value but now notice what happens
when we multiply by the count to try to
get the totals out so once again we get
something whose mean is the actual value
we want namely the total people the
total age of people named Betty white or
John but now the noise the standard
deviation has been scaled by this count
that we multiplied by and so now all of
a sudden the noise is actually quite
significant right centered at zero
standard deviation 24 that's like pretty
large when you're talking about the age
of a human being and the same thing
happens when we multiply the average age
of people named John by the count of
people named John we get this quite
significant noise and so when we take
the difference we do get something whose
mean is Betty White's age but again with
this very significant noise added on we
get an age of 140 150 4.4
which is obviously not Betty White's age
and so we've successfully blocked the
attack
we cannot recover the age of this
individual okay so why does this work at
its core what's going on here is that
the contribution of Betty White's entry
to this average query is negligible
relative to the noise so her entry does
contribute in an
aggregate everyone's entries contribute
in a way that gets you something very
accurate but as a single individual your
contribution just doesn't do that much
the noise sort of dominates and that
gives you the privacy and this is
essentially the core of what
differential privacy is so differential
privacy is a property of algorithms and
it limits how much the output of your
algorithm can change based on whether
your data is included or not and that's
the differential part of differential
privacy right so whether we include
Betty White's data in this data set or
not doesn't change the output of that
average query all that much
because the noise is sort of the larger
factor and this also means that there's
a limit to how much you can learn about
a person because their data was included
and it also limits the confidence you
can have about whether a person's data
was included and so this is the way that
we're gonna guarantee individual level
privacy now before I move on I just want
to give a couple of important caveats
about differential privacy the biggest
one is you'll notice that I've said
individual privacy differential privacy
as typically implemented doesn't provide
any sort of guarantee about privacy for
groups and that can be important so for
example you could conduct a study where
you learn about the average incidence of
tay-sachs in some subgroup and there
might be reasons that some group might
not want you to learn that information
right so marginalized groups might not
want to participate in your study or
your survey despite your individual
privacy guarantees and that's completely
reasonable and so you want to think
about you know if you're going out there
and you're gonna be applying privacy
techniques to your data you want to
think seriously about what you're trying
to accomplish and what your needs are
and differential privacy is just one of
several frameworks out there and the
right one is really going to depend on
your needs
that being said differential privacy
does give really nice guarantees for
Angela federal level privacy and is in
many ways very easy to analyze
mathematically and so that's what I'm
gonna focus on for this example okay so
I've shown you how to like make this
average query private but of course the
whole one of the big motivations of this
talk was to say we don't want to just
report averages we want to have
individual level data right
so how do we move toward individual
level data so in the next part of the
talk that's what I'll be discussing I'll
be saying I'll be talking about how we
can make fake individual level data and
the tool we're going to use for that is
generative adversarial networks so now
I'm going to give a quick introduction
to this technique so generative
adversarial networks are basically
neural networks and it's a technique for
training a neural network to generate
data
hence the generative part and it's
actually the combination of two distinct
neural networks one network called a
generator and one network called a
discriminator the generator network is
going to learn to make data that looks
like the real input data and the
discriminator is going to learn to tell
the difference between real data and the
fake data that the generator makes and
you're gonna alternate training these
networks and they sort of battle it out
and try to outwit each other and that's
sort of the adversarial part of
generative adversarial networks so I'm
gonna give a sort of toy example of what
this training might look like and the
example that I'm going to use is
generating digits handwritten digits
from the amnesty data set if you're
familiar with that data set if you're
not it's just hen written images of
digits so the generator is gonna take
some random noise as its input
Illustrated here we pass it to the
generator and it's gonna make a fake
image of a digit now notice to start out
with right the generator doesn't know
anything it's just like a random network
and so it's just gonna output this
random garbage that doesn't look like a
digit because it hasn't learned yet
we're gonna take the fake data and some
real data and we're gonna feed it to the
discriminator Network and notice again
at this point the discriminator doesn't
really know anything so it's kind of
guesses at random maybe it says they're
both good
I don't know and so now we're gonna
update the discriminator and say hey no
the top one is fake the bottom one is
real update your parameters and try to
do a better job of you know
distinguishing these two so now once
again we take some random input pass it
to the generator again the generator
hasn't really learned anything past
these the past the fake data and the
real data to the discriminator and now
at this point the discriminator knows
some things and so it can say oh that
top one is fake that bottom one is real
so discriminators doing okay generator
is not doing so well so we're gonna tell
the generator hey you should make stuff
that the discriminator is gonna like the
discriminator is gonna think israel and
we update its parameters based on that
so now we take some more random noise
pass it at the generator and notice now
it's making something that like if you
kind of squint it kind of looks like a
digit right you can see the outline of a
for a little bit less randomness in
there so we take that the real data
pass it to the discriminator and maybe
at this point right the discriminator
didn't have to work that hard to
distinguish these images maybe it was
using some really core statistical
properties to tell them apart so it's
it's still not doing a great job it's
like fooled by this not very convincing
digit so once again we update the
discriminator we say hey that top one is
fake the bottom one is real update your
parameters generate another image take
another real image now the discriminator
knows the difference and will feed this
one spat once more into the generator
say hey make stuff more like the stuff
on the bottom than the stuff on the top
and now maybe the generator is able to
make quite convincing digits that are
going to be sufficient for our purpose
to say here's a fake digit we can make
fake tidge it's all we want and the
discriminator can't tell the difference
because they're good enough okay so you
might be thinking okay here's our
framework for generating synthetic data
so now we're good you know if you make
synthetic data it's all private but as I
said earlier right that's not
necessarily going to be sufficient why
not so we actually have to make the
generator network model private and
there's a question of what it means for
a model to be private this might seem a
little weird right but the reality is
that models essentially memorize facts
about training data and you can use that
fact to basically extract information
about the training data that was fed in
to train the network so you can often
reliably guess whether a record was
included in training or not which
violates differential privacy right you
shouldn't be able to tell whether my
data was included in a data set based on
the model now you might think memorizing
facts that sounds like overfitting right
so maybe we can just do some
regularization maybe we you know put a
penalty on the on the size of the
weights
maybe we do drop out but unfortunately
techniques for preventing overfitting
just aren't quite sufficient to actually
protect individual level privacy so what
can we do instead so there's at least
like three broad approaches that you can
see out there in the literature for
making models private the first one is
to add noise to the training data but as
I set up and start right if you add
noise to the training data the amount of
noise you have to add is just so massive
that it basically kills any utility that
you had so it doesn't really work you
can add noise to the trained parameters
so you you know run your model your
neural network or whatever like normal
you get out some parameters and then you
add some noise to the end of that this
like kind of works but again the amount
of utility you lose the amount of
information you lose is larger than you
would really want and so the last
technique which is typically the most
effective is to add noise to the
gradients during training right so the
gradients are just the things sort of
feeding the information back to the
network telling it how to update itself
and what we say is you're not actually
going to get the fully faithful
information about how you should update
you're gonna get a slightly modified
slightly noisy version of that and so
thinking back to the example with the
Betty White average age example right
there her contribution as a single
record to the average was negligible
relative to the noise and that was what
guaranteed privacy and here the
contribution of any one record to the
gradient is going to be negligible
relative to the noise and that's what's
going to ensure privacy for the trained
network so this overall approach was was
proven to work for generative
adversarial networks by a paper last
year so adding noise to the gradients
plus a couple of restrictions on what
the architecture look like is enough to
make generative adversarial networks
differentially private and so I took
this model and implemented it in an open
source Python package using PI torch in
in theory it's compatible with any kind
of data that you might have although I
have some helper tools to make this
easier to do with categorical data sets
so the code is
line if you want to take a look at it
you can play around with it try out some
examples see how it works okay so so
I've gone over some basics of like
generative adversarial networks and
differential privacy but now the
question is like does any of this stuff
actually work so in the last part of the
talk I'm gonna give an example using
data from the US Census make some
synthetic data and see like does this
approach actually work so a little bit
of background on the data on the data
I'm looking at comes from the American
Community Survey or ACS and as part of
that the census releases individual
level data known as the public use
microdata sample or PUMS data so I took
the 2017 ACS PUMS data from the state of
Illinois and I looked at four variables
from this so age which I've been into
nine categories marriage which comes in
five categories means of transportation
to work which comes in twelve categories
and schooling which comes in 24
categories so here's just an example of
some like randomly selected entries from
this data set at the top you can see
someone who's between 56 and 65 has an
associate's degree is widowed and drives
to work you can see a 26 to 35 year old
who has a bachelor's degree has never
been married and subway to work and so
on and so forth so there's just a whole
bunch of records that look like this
corresponding to individual people in
the state of Illinois okay so how do we
take this and turn this into some
synthetic data so there's about 600,000
input data points in this data set first
I convert them to a one hot encoding so
just for the sake of the network so for
each level of the category there's just
a column you know that's a 1 or a 0
depending on whether that that record
falls within that category then I create
a generator Network and a discriminator
network and I'll talk about the
architectures of those in just a second
I train the Ganner generative
adversarial network so the package takes
care of most of this for you and then
generate the same number of output data
points as there were in the input
okay so here's a quick illustration of
the generator architecture so at the
bottom you have this like bell curve
representing the Gaussian noise that is
the input to the generator that gets
passed into a fully connected layer that
maps to some hidden units you pass that
through a non-linearity to do some
threshold England our Kotecha where you
have a fully connected layers Plus this
Gumbel softmax
and that's going to be the thing that
basically maps from these hidden units
onto the categories that we want as the
outputs so it's it's sort of a multi
output model with an output for each
category so age marriage transit
schooling so what does this look like in
code for this package right you can just
implement all of these things as pipe
torch modules for the neural networks
that you're building
so here I've just used the sequential
module so there's a linear unit there's
the non-linearity and then I wrote a PI
torch module in this package to just
make handling this like multi category
output a little bit easier and then you
also have to define a function to create
the noise that's the input to the
generator Network so this is pretty
simple it's just Gaussian noise and so
as for the discriminator architecture
you'll notice that the input of the
discriminator architecture is the same
as the output of the generator
architecture right because the
discriminator is going to be taking this
generated data and also real data and
trying to say is this real or not we map
through a fully connected layer to get
to some hidden units pass that through a
non-linearity and then map the results
of that down onto a single value that's
going to be our representation of
whether the discriminator thinks this is
real data or not so it's like assessment
of how good this data is and so again
the code for this is just going to be
another PI torch module our linear layer
our non-linearity and then our linear
layer mapping down onto a single unit
okay so once we have on the left all of
that code setup it's pretty simple to
put this into the can and train it
so first we just passed the generator
discriminator and noise function into
the dpw gain class we trained it on the
real data set and then we generate data
of the same size as the input data set
okay so before I show you what the
generated data looks like I'm gonna show
you some some of the real data again so
that we can see like a side-by-side
comparison so here's one way of looking
at the real census data this is a cross
tabulation showing counts for age and
marriage as categories so on the y-axis
you have age increasing from bottom to
top and on the x-axis you have marriage
categories so never married or under 15
married separated divorced and widowed
and then in each cell you have a count
of the people who fall within that
category that combination of categories
and then the coloring is just showing
you in a different individual
representation that same sort of count
information so the darker the cell is
the more people who fall in that
category so you'll notice right like
there's this large concentration in the
bottom left of people between the age of
0 and 17 who have never been married or
are under the age of 15 that makes a lot
of sense right you can see that there's
sort of a concentration an increasing
concentration of married people as you
get a little bit older so 26 up through
like 66 and then you know if you look up
in the top right corner you can see that
like people are more likely to be
widowed as they get you know much older
okay so that's what the real data looks
like so now I'm gonna show the same
crosstab on the right for the synthetic
data and what you can see is right that
to a first approximation these look
extremely similar right like the basic
heat map is is extremely similar same
you know same areas of high heat same
areas of low heat and so we've captured
most of this sort of a lot of this
correlational information that you saw
in the original data so we know that
most young people have never been
married or are young we know that sort
of marriage increases as people get
older we see that you know
Widow Inge increases as people get much
older so you know I think to a first
approximation we've done a very good job
of capturing the information in the
original data now of course it's going
to depend on your application whether
some of the discrepancies here are large
enough to be of concern but I think this
shows that you know again the the basic
approach is largely working here is
commute means of commute to work versus
age so on the y-axis you have a whole
bunch of commute categories bicycle bus
car truck van and so on and so forth and
then age categories not quite as much
information in this graph what you can
largely see is just this one really dark
line that's because basically everyone
in Illinois drives to work unfortunately
so but again you can see that you know
the information the broad contours of
the information are largely captured and
then just to show that this even works
with a really large number of categories
I know this is a lot to look at I don't
expect you to see everything in it but
this is schooling versus age so on the
y-axis you have a highest degree
completed from like no schooling up
through doctorate degree and then again
an age on the x-axis and what you can
see is right like most young people are
in grade school not a whole lot of like
seventeen year olds with Doctorate
degrees and of course the synthetic data
is capturing that as well and then again
some similar to some other patterns with
respect to the distribution of like high
school diploma a bachelor's degree and
so on so to sort of sum up differential
privacy is a useful framework for
understanding individual level privacy
so differential privacy limits your
ability to tell if someone's data was
included in your data set and it also
limits what you can learn about someone
because their data was included and so
that's a very powerful guarantee
additionally generative adversarial
networks can be a great technique for
making fake data so we saw that we can
make this data that kind of looks like
the real stuff and by combining these
two approaches you can make useful data
sets that reach
can potentially use but that also
protect individual level privacy so
again this code is all online and open
source if you want to try it out
yourself
both the census data an example that I
used in this talk is in there or you can
try it on your own datasets and then I
have at the bottom my contact
information and again the slide link in
case you missed it so I'll take
questions yeah so there are sort of
mathematical proofs that like if that in
that the generative adversarial network
should learn to match the distribution
of the original input dataset so in that
sense there's a guarantee in practice
like guns are like this complicated
dynamical system and so it's often hard
to like actually prove or meet
convergence and so in practice you might
not actually like capture the disturb'
input distribution and then also like
what you can capture in the input
distribution depends on the architecture
of your network so if your network has
the capability of representing the input
distribution then it will be able to
capture that but if it doesn't have that
capacity than it won't so it's some
combination of like I think ideally if
you were actually doing this in practice
you want to like do some Diagnostics
afterwards to like make sure that this
has gone okay you can also start by
training the network and tuning the
network without the noise and privacy so
that you can do all of your like fitting
and optimization there and then add the
noise and so that you're not like
breaking the privacy protections by like
overfitting the private data to the real
data so yeah like in practice there's
some mathematical guarantees and proofs
but like in real world applications not
exactly
so for the Betty White example I know
I'm after you added the noise like her
age obviously Rio it was like 150 but I
wonder yeah so that's that's absolutely
right there is a sense in which it leaks
some information about her so the way
differential privacy works is the amount
of noise you add sort of influences how
much you can learn about someone right
and so if you you know we're very
concerned about that and wanted to make
sure that someone couldn't even learn
like that someone was at all like on the
older range you would need to add a bit
more noise and that would decrease your
utility a little bit and so like
differential privacy is not a guarantee
that you can't learn anything about
someone but what it is is sort of a
limit on how much you can sort of inform
your distribution and that's going to
depend on how much noise you add yeah so
a couple of things there so one of the
reasons that I was looking at
categorical data is that actually most
of the literature you see out there on
Ganz and differential privacy is looking
at things like images or other kinds of
continuous data so I was actually very
curious like how these would perform
with categorical data
that being said continuous data like
images is a little bit different from
like continuous data like you know real
values you'll notice that I bend edge
but you could make the argument like
maybe that's not really the appropriate
way to treat age and I haven't really
played around with that yet the other
thing I'll say is that sometimes this
particular technique can be finicky if
you're mixing categorical and continuous
data so I don't really have a great
answer for you there but it's definitely
something that I'm interested in
exploring more whether you can really
make this work in a unified framework
with both continuous and categorical
outputs
as like one of two zero right so it's
generating those like one hot encoding
zazz the outputs of the zero are one
within the categories and then those
just get mapped back onto the categories
so there's some information potentially
being thrown away especially with ones
that have levels ideally the network is
like doing some feature engineering and
learning that information in practice I
have like a pretty shallow Network that
probably can't learn that kind of
representational information but if you
had more sophisticated enriched data you
could potentially like hope that the
network learns those features or like
enforce some of that information into
the structure of the network know so in
this case I've just tried like this
particular you know I mean I fiddled
with the architecture a little bit but I
haven't played around too much with in
theory you could use any kind of network
in practice the structure of the network
informs like how much noise you have to
add and and things that you do with the
weights and so some networks are gonna
require sort of more noise and that
might mess with your utility a bit but
the package again is written in a way
where like you can throw in any PI torch
module that you want so it's easy to
play around and experiment with other
with other types of networks
one more did you
that's question there's a lot of like
upcoming litigation of that about how
much data company's been stored maintain
do you know if any
yeah so I'm not aware of any court cases
looking at this specifically I think
there's a few things so first of all
some of those new regulations regulate
collection of data and so the approach
that I've discussed here assumes that
you've already collected the data there
are differential privacy techniques that
like basically apply the privacy before
the data is collected and so in that
case that might be sufficient but a
technique like this that isn't designed
to do that would not satisfy those
requirements beyond that I think you
know I I sort of I I doubt that any
legislation is going to be written in a
way that that can fully like decide this
question and I think there's probably
just going to be a long process of us
figuring out like what is an acceptable
level of privacy for accomplishing the
goals that we care about with that
legislation I know that's not a super
satisfying answer but I think this is
all just sort of starting to get worked
out okay thanks everyone
[Applause]